cette semaine notre coup de coeur et le
film les figures de l'ombre réalisé par
théodore melfi le destin extraordinaire
de trois scientifiques afro américaines
qui ont permis aux états unis de prendre
la tête de la conquête spatiale
grâce à la mise en orbite de
l'astronaute john glenn maintenu dans
l'ombre de leurs collègues masculins et
dans celle d'un pays en proie à de
profondes inégalités leur histoire
longtemps resté méconnu est enfin porté
à l'écran à l'heure où les questions
raciales sont toujours d'actualité le
film porte un regard sur la ségrégation
qui prend ici tout son relief le
spectateur suivra avec intérêt cette
aventure particulièrement forte
grâce au dynamisme au charme et au
charisme de ses trois femmes fières et
admiral pris le soin qu'il apporte au
dialogue à la précision du montage donne
au film un rythme ultra cadence et avec
une efficacité redoutable
reposant sur des faits réels ce long
métrage touchera le spectateur avec le
récit de ces trois destins hors du
commun
je ne sais même pas si je pourrai suivre
catherine tu es plus forte en maths que
le plus fort d'entre eux
et est parti puis 300 heures moi aussi
ça m'a semblé lent jamais là quand on
vous cherche ou disparaissez vous comme
ça les toilettes pour joindre couleurs
sont à 15 cents bêtes nous graverons la
montagne ensemble ou pas du tout
les figures de l'ombre est proposé en
version française et en version
originale et est à découvrir cette
semaine à l'espace philippe moi je suis
content que la nasa n'avait pas tiré un
trait sur l'intelligence